en sur public sénat
marine le pen la présidente du front
national est l'invité de preuves par 3
en association avec une agence france
presse et dailymotion
bonsoir madame le pen merci d'être avec
nous vous affichez en cette rentrée
vos ambitions en ironisant sur
l'obsession que vous êtes devenu dites
vous pour l'ump pour le parti socialiste
le psychodrame fillon votre main tendue
sous la forme d'une charte pour les
élections municipales votre banalisation
dans l'opinion alors que le chef de
l'état met en garde contre l'abandon des
valeurs héritées de notre histoire et
des principes fondamentaux de la
république nous occuperons durant cette
émission pour laquelle me rejoindront
raffler mano de l' agence france-presse
et perrine tarneaud de public sénat
d'abord le retour apparemment dû ni-ni
l'ump réaffirment à l'occasion d'un
bureau politique qu'il n'est pas
question d'appeler à voter pour un
candidat fn et vous renvoie à votre
extrémisme et votre sectarisme que
répondez-vous à fillon copé d'avoir un
très objectivement sanata ça c'est peu
je ne cache pas parce que je pense que
les partis politiques concourent à
l'expression des différents courants de
pensée
or j'ai le sentiment que les partis
politiques aujourd'hui ne pense qu'à une
chose c'est comment mettre en place des
tactiques politiciennes pour se faire
réélire on sait même plus pourquoi ils
veulent être réélus d'ailleurs parce
qu'il parle plus du tout de politique
c'est leur problème c'est pas le mien ça
ne m'est avis qu'ils font aussi nous
affaire ne m'intéresse pas pour une
raison simple si vous laissez qu'ils
sont en train de débattre autour de la
mort c'est front républicain il c'est la
veillée funèbre du front républicain
certains visent à lui un front
républicain
mais qui est morte aujourd'hui par
exemple ces gens pendant la discussion
porte aujourd'hui sur le chacun tire un
peu la couverture à lui
monsieur borloo rêve que de pouvoir de
profiter d'un petit bout non mais moi je
n'ai pas besoin de tout cela moi je
porte un projet aux français ils sont
d'accord avec moi ou ils sont pas
d'accord ils jugent ceux qui nous ont
gouvernés
s'il juge que ceux qui nous ont
gouvernés ne nous ont pas répondu à
leurs préoccupations et bien ils
regardent l'offre qui existe l'offre qui
existe c'est celle du front national
dont je pense qu'il correspond un dans
le projet qu'il veut mettre en oeuvre à
ce que les français attendent alors nous
les choses sont claires nous ne ferons
pas d'accord avec l'ump ne font pas eu
d'accord avec le parti socialiste nous
avons pour par exemple pour les
municipales une charte sommes prêts à
accueillir des patriotes de droite et de
gauche sur des engagements politiques
voilà et je pense qu'en faisant cela et
bien nous remettons un grand p à la
politique là où manifestement il ne
l'écrivent plus qu'avec un peu de ça
c'est que vous estimez remporté une
victoire idéologique quand des ténors de
l'ump déplace à droite parfois très
adroite leur curseur quand on les entend
par exemple sur l'immigration oui le
droit du sol
mais attention quand tu es simplement
tandis que cette victoire et delaunay
incontestablement ce sont des victoires
et de logique puisque c'est nous qui
avons contribué à obliger les partis
politiques pas seulement d'ailleurs de
l'ump mais également du ps à venir sur
des thématiques telles que le
protectionnisme tels que l'existence de
frontières t que la maîtrise des flux
migratoires sur les questions
économiques et autres programmes
dangereux
j'entends j'entendais vous géré pendant
la campagne européenne
ils ne manqueront pas de venir vous
parler de l'europe protectrice concept
tout à fait nouveau dans leur bouche
ils ne manqueront pas d'évoquer la
nécessaire souveraineté de la france
après en avoir vidé totalement le
contenu je n'ai absolument aucun doute
sur le fait que nous serons la force
d'attraction notamment aux européennes
et que vous retrouverez dans la bouche
d'un certain nombre qu'ils soient de
droite ou de gauche des formulations
très proches de celles qui sont
exprimées par le front national
on verra on parler d'aidé européenne ou
penser votre objectif est d'arriver en
tête
oui c'est notre objectif je crois que
c'est une hypothèse qui est parfaitement
crédible parce qu'encore une fois l'ump
et le ps vont avoir la pire des
difficultés pendant ces élections
européennes c'est d'essayer de montrer
une divergence entre eux et pour arrêt
pour le scrutin de 2010 est est ce que
nicolas sarkozy a raison de penser que
c'est ce qu'il ne dit apparemment qu'il
est le seul à pouvoir faire barrage à
votre progression
je ne sais pas et je ne crois pas que
nicolas sarkozy reviendra mais tout ça
me paraît loin et est loin loin dans le
temps séparément système de vote dans le
temps mais surtout loin des
préoccupations pour l'instant des
français non je crois que vous vous
trompez le sens de mon discours à
marseille n'était pas 2017
c'était de tracer une perspective
politique aux français d'arrêter
justement de faire de la politique à la
petite semaine qu'est ce qu'on va faire
la semaine prochaine ou dans un mois
c'est une perspective française où
allons-nous voilà ce que je veux montrer
aux français et pas qu'est ce qu'on va
négocier dans les trois mois qui
viennent alors au soir de votre discours
donc à marseille lors de vos universités
d'été françois hollande a rappelé la
nécessité de digues pour préserver at il
dit les principes fondamentaux de la
république et arrêter notre histoire
est ce que avec vous nous cesserions
d'être fiers de nos valeurs fiers de
nous mêmes le dit françois hollande et
tout ça est extrêmement vague d'ailleurs
jamais de manière précise ces j'en
explique en quoi le front national se
mettrait hors des valeurs de la
république
moi je suis pour une république une et
indivisible je suis donc à ce titre
contre le communautarisme contre la
discrimination positive
je suis pour la démocratie auquel le
front national se soumet avec un grand
enthousiasme d'ailleurs en toutes
circonstances une vraie démocratie
puisque la france
eh ben je suis mais bien entendu pour le
pour la proportionnelle et je suis pour
le référendum d'initiative populaire
c'est-à-dire le la plus aboutie des
démocraties l'avait dit également comme
une fois au pouvoir et bien vous ne
ferez pas plaisir à certains à l'anti
doit avoir peur eh bien ceux qui abusent
voilà ceux qui abusent du système c'est
qu'il ne respecte pas la loi ce qui
viole nos valeurs ce qu'ils veulent
imposer leur mode de vie aux français
ceux qui fraudent et qui met en danger
notre modèle social
ceux qui se comportent comme des rapaces
comme c'est le cas par exemple pour la
grande finance et pour la banque
oui à cela effectivement je l'avais vu
le l'annoncent je ne le ferais
probablement pas plaisir mais ça tous
les partis s'accordent à dire qu'il faut
combattre les abus on en attend à droite
à gauche se sont prononcés sont pas si
longtemps mais on ne voit pas beaucoup
sauf qu'avec moi on va le voir
voilà c'est à dire que j'ai entendu mon
monsieur hollande dire qu'ils allaient
lutter contre la grande finance rien vu
un je n'ai rien vu venir
je n'ai pas vu la génération au niveau
européen reconnaissait le monde on n'est
qu'à essayer de mettre de régulation sur
les marchés boursiers mais non je ne
l'aï bien sûr que non je ne le reconnaît
pas la première des choses à faire était
d'ailleurs de séparer les banques de
dépôt et des banques d'affaires
en réalité ce a accouché d'une souris
et rien n'a été fait en ce domaine alors
voilà encore une fois moi je ferai ce
pourquoi j'aurais été élu alors à
comprendre l'europe puisqu'on en parle
même à jonah j'aimerais connaître votre
réponse maintenant au président de la
commission josé manuel barroso qui a
dénoncé le populisme tous les populismes
de gauche comme de droite at il dit mais
il vous visez vous qui fait de l'europe
et de l'euro le bouc émissaire et il
estime que vous proposez des solutions
simplistes à des problèmes complexes
pourquoi c'est ce que le monsieur
barroso il défend un système que je que
je combats par conséquent c'est pas très
étonnant qui viennent sur ce terrain là
c'est quoi le populisme c'est le
gouvernement du peuple par le peuple et
pour le peuple on avait compris que
monsieur barroso est un adversaire
déclarée des pubs dans son esprit c'est
qu'il tient dans le plus grand mépris
c'est si vrai d'ailleurs que on n'écoute
pas ce que les peuples disent on les
ruines ont les pille et de se croit
quand il s'exprime par référendum
eh bien on se débrouille avec nono
servile élus députés sénateurs pour
venir contredire la volonté populaire
donc comme monsieur barroso soit
l'ennemi des peuples
ça m'étonne pas qu'ils attaquent à celle
qui défend le peuple ne m'étonne pas mon
petit poussin est dans la droite ligne
sans difficulté de ce qui se passe
depuis des années alors vous avez évoqué
les faux nez des marchés financiers il
ya un instant marine le pen comme étant
à l'origine note de la crise
il ya également le l'endettement lors
nettement des pays savent où le
reconnaissait l endettement des pays
sûrs maintenant
non mais deux milliards d'euros pour la
france par exemple oui tiens c'est
d'ailleurs au passage n'aurait tenu de
notre endettement va s'aggraver non
parce que toutes les politiques
d'austérité visait à réduire le déficit
non seulement elle ne les réduit pas
mais comme d'ailleurs c'était prévisible
puisque c'était cas en grèce était le
cas en espagne ou au portugal
cette petite de sai t elle aggrave les
déficits et donc elle la gr la dette est
ce que les français savent que sur ces 9
mai 1950 milliards parce qu'on va
arriver à 5 95 % du pib en 2014 et à
1500 milliards d'intérêts que nous avons
versé aux banques depuis 1973
ça je pense que c'était un peu le noeud
gordien sur lequel personne ne veut
intervenir des prêts à alourdir
l'endettement de combien de milliards
d'euros même puisque en sortant de
l'euro est vue d'améliorer une
dévaluation ça coûterait cher à pinon
monsieur non je crois que vous à chaque
fois d'ailleurs il y à un pan de notre
projet que vous omettez totalement
d'indiquer aux français c'est que le
retour à la monnaie nationale
permettrait certes d'avoir une monnaie
qui ne soit pas surévaluer comme c'est
le cas aujourd'hui et dont chacun
s'accorde même monsieur moscovici c'est
pour dire à dire que l est un des impôts
veniant majeur à notre compétitivité
notre monnaie est trop cher pour notre
économie bon / / / ça chacun s'accorde à
le dire mais le retour aux monnaies
nationales va permettre aussi de pouvoir
remettre la banque de france dans ses
prérogatives et autoriser la banque de
france a prêté au trésor sans intérêt
plutôt que d'être entre les mains des
marchés financiers qui demain je elle
restera aux mains des marchés financiers
c'est avec elle venait d'évaluation
complet cher non seulement parce que le
privé financera le privé et le public
elle financera le public or nous avons
dit nous lorsque la banque de france
sera rétablie dans ses prérogatives nous
monétisons la dette ce qui est un tout
petit peu en train d'être fait
d'ailleurs au niveau européen on trouve
ça très bien vivre au cap a bien lieu
national bon ben moi je dis si l'un
c'est bien l'autre c'est bien aussi sur
ses nous maîtrisons 5% du pib chaque
année le fmi a dit que à 5% on
n'augmente pas reprendre le contrat et à
la finance j'ai pas dis que ça coûterait
rien ça d'ailleurs été ça a d'ailleurs
été chiffré dans meilleur g
ça a été chiffrée je crois me souvenir à
4% du pib mais savard et créent de
l'emploi nous c'est très très lourd a
bien joué et le chômage monsieur n'était
pas de l'anc année ambitieux avec les
cycles et chez moi je veux sortir de
cette de cette spirale
or aujourd'hui on ne remboursera jamais
la dette et vous le savez et tous nos
dirigeants le savent et il ya un malheur
c'est que aujourd'hui où nous sommes
totalement dépendants des marchés
financiers que va-t-il se passer si les
taux d'intérêt montent et bien si les
taux d'intérêt montent les 20 30
milliards de sacrifices que l'on a
demandé aux français seront rayés d'un
simple trait de plume
je veux sortir de cette spirale là alors
certes il y aura un léger ralentissement
mais il y aura un retour des
exportations
un retour non mais d'accord mais en
retour un retour de l'emploi parce que
moi monsieur je veux bien tout ce qu'on
veut mais avec quoi actuellement vous
rembourser la dette
avec quelle création de richesse parce
que pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
croissance il n'y a pas de création de
richesse il n'y a pas d'emploi alors on
parle de la justice si vous voulez
maintenant avec la crise un taux bien et
qui a été sévèrement uv dimanche à
marseille vous êtes pour le tout
carcéral ça vous l'avait bien dit je
deviens un incendie dans votre discours
on est d'accord chaque peine de prison
doit être exécuté il y en a cent mille
qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui généralement
ce sont des peines de moins 2
deux ans donc combien de prison voulez
vous construire urgemment 40000 places
parce que 40 places de prison ça nous
mettra au niveau de la moyenne des pays
européens par rapport à leur population
urgemment 40000 places
oui bien sûr il faut les construire
aujourd'hui il ya soixante mille détenus
qui sont entassés dans 190
établissements
vous avez parfaitement raison et il y a
moyen de manière assez rapide de pouvoir
toutes les peines sont exécutées ils
font plus que doubler en fait le nom
monsieur on encore appeler non parce que
vous
ce que l'on ignorait probablement c'est
que dans ces cent mille peines il ya
énormément de récidivistes à dire des
gens qui ont déjà à leur actif de même
trois caps 5 pen qui ne sont pas
exécutées d'ailleurs on voit ce que ça
peut donner dans le sentiment d'impunité
qui évidemment se développe à l'égard de
ces délinquants voix rauque apte il n'y
a pas d'alternative à l'alcool
l'incarcération à il peut y avoir des
algues en avoir il peut y en avoir il
peut y en avoir mais je crois que ça
n'est pas le je pense que toute sanction
doit être doit être exécutée car si la
sanction n'est pas exécutée ne remplit
pas néanmoins le rôle qu'on éloigne que
la loi il ya des probations des arts et
il peut y en avoir pour les
primo-délinquants par exemple il peut
mais pour les primo-délinquants une fois
pour les primo-délinquants on peut
envisager par exemple un sursis ça
s'appelait bon le problème si vous
voulez c'est qu'aujourd'hui grâce à
madame taubira mentionné que la suit pas
la prison dès la première que la
condamnation ça n'est que la suite non
c'est la sanction la sanction ça n'est
que la suite de la fin de l'impunité
accordée par madame dati aujourd'hui le
sursis ne sera pas révoquer
automatiquement ça veut dire qu'on va
vous mettre à supprimer la prochaine
fois que vous venez vous aurez aussi un
sursis mais la fois d'après vous aurez
encore un sursis moyennant quoi c'est
exactement comme si on ne condamnez pas
qu'avez vous pensé de la frère de
jean-marie le pen au sujet du bijoutier
nice à sa place j'aurais fait la même
chose d'assez son opinion c'est pas la
vôtre non moi j'ai pas envie de me
retrouver dans la cour d'assises
valls a présenté à nice des mesures qui
sont réclamés par les bijoutiers se
disent plutôt satisfaits on leur a parlé
de la géolocalisation de la
vidéosurveillance deux rondes de police
plus fréquentes mais le ministre
d'intérieur elle dit qu'il n'y a pas de
recette miracle
attention il faut du travail pour vous
il ya des recettes miracles
oui mais c'est marrant quand même parce
que tous les pays de l' ocde ont vu
baisser la délinquance et la criminalité
de manière massive l'éclat france où ça
augmente c'est donc manifestement les
recettes appliquées en france ne sont
pas des bonnes et que c'est qu'ils sont
appliqués dans les pays de l'oci des
souvenirs
alors avant d'aborder maintenant votre
ambition pour les élections municipales
de l'an prochain pour lesquelles vous
lancez des centaines de listes voyons
comment vous y prenez par exemple à
boulogne-sur-mer la ville du ministre
fabrique plus de villiers avant
d'accueillir le raf est là hermano de l'
agence france-presse
le reportage de paul bouffard qui s'est
rendu sur place vous êtes sur le terrain
bien sûr fait passer le message
ce n'est pas une réunion des jeunes
militants fn non antoine golliot réuni
ses troupes avant la bataille
à 28 ans cet ingénieur n'a pas de mal à
trouver ses quarante deux colistiers
avec toi j'ai romain tu seras un nouveau
co listiers pour la liste boule bleue
marine
donc je vais te faire remplir tout de
suite ce formulaire d'engagement dans
une ville ancrée depuis 50 ans à gauche
il est un de ces trentenaires à l'assaut
des mairies de france c'est une réalité
surtout notre électorat à une grande
partie de jeunes
d'ailleurs un dernier sondage montré que
36 % des jeunes voter front national
votre et front national que ce soit
d'ailleurs pour des élections locales
municipales et cette marée de jeunes
frontistes n'est pas du goût des
opposants à l'ump locale
c'est un jeune aussi qui s'engage mais
pour david dubois 27 ans la jeunesse
n'excuse pas tout le discours radical
est toujours là aujourd'hui en ce qui
concerne localement donc ce monsieur
golliot qui a 28 ans et qui a comme
modèle monsieur haider je sais pas si
vous connaissez le néo nazis autrichien
mettre des jeunes pour mettre des jeunes
c'est bon c'est pas là c'est parce qu'il
faut faire et aujourd'hui moi je me
poserai la question marine le pen si
demain on enfin entre guillemets la
chance de la croiser pourquoi avoir mis
une tête de liste qui a incommodé la
nouvelle année aux nazis à part la
provocation
aux dernières cantonales antoine
beaulieu se seraient déclarés séduits
par le style de jorg haider à la mairie
derrière les hauts murs du bastion
socialiste on ne s'inquiète pas plus que
ça ce ne sont que des jeunes en plein
coup de com ils n'ont pas d'espacé
véritablement je veux dire de parole et
de
tribune donc les conseils municipaux
vont devenir des tribunes pour ces
personnes qui vont avoir la l'occasion
de pouvoir en découdre peut-être avec
avec les politiques je pense que c'est
surtout ça donc il faut que tu sois au
maximum présents sur le marché
c'est important que les candides côté
électeurs que les électeurs du front
national
toute voix change dans la permanence
d'antoine golliot séances de coaching
avec le responsable départemental
on a secrétaire général un ami qui
s'appelle steve briois qui a une
expérience et marine le pen lorsqu'elle
a nommé secrétaire général a voulu de
faire des mondes voor dupliquer la
méthode partout en france il doit c'est
ce que nous faisons ici sur la commune
de boulogne-sur-mer
aux dernières législatives le front
national a remporté près de 14% des
suffrages
voilà nous avons d'abord sur votre
candidat à boulogne donc le fait qu'il
soit manifestement admiratif de jorg
haider vous choquer ce que 7e je croyais
fait leur leader est mort peut-être
qu'il le trouvait beau manifester non
pas pour son physique pour s'équiper
oui bon cjd excusez moi mais enfin il a
été au gouvernement je crois pendant un
assez long moment sans que ça pose deux
problèmes majeurs marie le pen bonjour
alors pour les municipales en vue
d'éventuelles alliances locales vous
proposer un pacte qui rassemble toutes
leurs propositions comme je lis refusait
d'augmenter la fiscalité agir pour
assurer la tranquillité la sécurité
lutter contre les gaspillages
est ce qu'au fond c'est pas un petit peu
fourre tout non je crois pas non nous
nous avons dix points qui sont des
points incontournables ce n'est pas
notre programme municipal d'ailleurs le
programme municipal sera rendu public
dans une convention municipal qui aura
lieu à la mi novembre qui sera le
démarrage de la campagne de l'alliance
est vendu exactement ce sont les points
que nous considérons comme
incontournable est-ce que
l'arrêt des subventions aux associations
communautaristes et pour tous non et
pourquoi nous le mettons parce que nous
voyons que l'ump et le ps ont n'ont eu
de cesse que de financer les
associations communautaristes dans leur
ville pourquoi c'est une vindicte
options comme par exemple l'association
des cèpes à des portugais
vim l'association communautaire et sur
go c'est une association communautariste
oui puis la république la république n'a
pas à financer les associations
communautaristes nous lui voulons lutter
contre le communautarisme quel qu'il
soit c'est le média que l'association
doit disparaître ça veut dire qu'elle
n'a pas à recevoir d'argent public elle
doit vivre
somme toute des adhésions de ses membres
il faut qu'une association répondre à
l'intérêt général et pas des intérêts
particuliers leur a foncé dessus
mais c'est le refus de l'augmentation de
la fiscalité pourquoi nous le mettons
pas ce que nous avons vu que dans toutes
les villes ump ps
la fiscalité locale a explosé et donc
l'autre formation politique le
promettent également la fiscalité sur
l'ensemble du mandat vous êtes d'aller
seul d'accord monsieur mais non
excusez-moi mais je regarde un petit peu
je juge aussi un petit peu le maçon au
pied du mur quoi je m'aperçois que
monsieur copé nous explique qu'il veut
une baisse massive de la fiscalité mais
il voulait mettre la tva 24% et
lorsqu'ils ont été au pouvoir ils ont
créé sous nicolas sarkozy
plus de quarante taxe est augmentée de
30 milliards alourdie de 30 milliards la
fiscalité aussi tendance à pas le croire
si on vous pose la question sur ce pacte
également c'est parce qu'on n'y trouve
pas les marqueurs les fondamentaux du
front national par exemple quid de la
préférence nationale que vous vous
appelez priorités nationales pourquoi
elle et pas dans ce pack mais l'epa dans
ce pack parce que pour l'instant elle ne
peut pas être mise en oeuvre
elle serait t'il légale et par
conséquent je respecte la loi
nous nous avons voulons mettre en oeuvre
la priorité nationale mais nous le
ferons en gagnant les élections
présidentielles papinghem
élections législatives au risque de
décevoir un peu votre électorat parce
que vous savez bien qu'à l'applaudimètre
notamment dans votre discours c'était le
cas à marseille ce qui marche c'est
aussi c'est quand vous parler
d'immigration comme il souhaite à ses
qualités qu'ont scandé on est chez nous
par d'immigration en matière de sécurité
le faire à très peu pour voir monsieur
vous me conseillez quoi de violer la loi
non je vous demande en fait qu'est ce
qui fait l'identité du fonds de commerce
quand c est ce que vous me conseillez de
violer la loi non bon quand il ya des
faits parce qu'elle était fait vitrolles
par exemple qu'on doit changer au niveau
national tant qu'elles ne sont pas
changé nous sommes respectueux des lois
et par conséquent nous oeuvrons dans la
limite des lois de la république qui
sont certes extrêmement imparfaite et
que nous entendons changé en gagnant les
élections présidentielle et législatives
mais il n'est pas le temps de cela pour
l'instant donc on réitère pas
l'expérience qu'elle avait été menée à
vitrolles quant à lui une prime de
naissance aux mères d'enfants à 106
euros
c'était un petit peu l'erreur qui a été
commise c'est qu'on a voulu faire de ces
villes par un excès de zèle d'une
vitrine de la politique nationale
et ça n'est pas le cas voilà les
municipales ce sont les municipales à
chaque élection ses spécificités
et oui effectivement on ne commettra pas
à nouveau cette erreur
donc le bilan ce le bilan des mairies
frontiste globalement vous le trouvez
vous vous dites c'était plutôt une
erreur enfin on pense à orange
tout le long je pense qu'on est très
injuste parce que la réalité c'est que
tout le monde en tout cas sur le plan
des finances publiques la situation
s'est beaucoup améliorée je vous
rappelle encore une fois que jean marc
chevallier a été élu alors que la ville
était sous tutelle
monsieur à rex l'avait ruiné bon quand
il est parti ça s'est amélioré mais
cette sorte de volonté de faire des
laboratoires si vous voulez à mon avis
n'était pas une bonne idée de nous en
sommes rendu compte et puis il ya
quelques personnalités qui ont dépassé
dépasser la ligne mais la différence et
ça peut arriver à tous les mouvements
politiques d'accord avec moi la
différence c'est que nous on les reprend
pas ces gens là voyez on l'aimé pas
ministre alors que les autres partis
politiques ont plutôt tendance à ne pas
sanctionner lorsqu'ils ont des élus qui
commettent des erreurs pour mémoire jean
marie le chevallier il a été condamné
pour des mots tournement de fonds
publics observé comme monsieur ayrault
d'ailleurs qui est actuellement monsieur
premier ministre et qui a été condamné
lourdement sur le plan pénal n'est ce
pas ça ne l'a pas empêché de devenir
premier ministre
oui moi je mettrais pas j'en arrive
surveiller premier ministre aime ça peut
vous rassurer alors qu'elle était
blanchie pour monsieur ayrault la peine
a été effacée je crois ah mais ça
n'empêche pas qu'elle ait accord c'est
non mais ensuite
ah bah oui comme tout le monde un moment
au bout d'un moment ça sent du casier
judiciaire mais il n'a pas été blanchi
loin de là il a été condamné
définitivement
et puis il a bénéficié bengtsson tout de
la disparition de cette peine sur son
casier judiciaire voilà il fallait le
mentionnait bien sûr 2014
concrètement quelle ville espérez vous
emportez hénin-beaumont bien sûr mais
lesquels un forbach avec florian
philippot béziers avec robert ménard
vous misez sur combien de villes et
combien de grosses villes mais je me
sens pas voilà je ne vis pas serré
concernant un pari chaque ville gagne
est un succès puisqu'on en a pour
l'instant aucune et je pense que nous
pourrions effectivement avoir plus de
municipalités que nous n'avons jamais eu
historiquement au front national
et puis parallèlement à cela nous font
élire des centaines de conseillers
municipaux vous savez que j'y attache
une importance toute particulière car il
s'agit là d'une implantation locale de
cette politique de proximité
cette politique de responsabilité de
preuve aussi que pourront apporter ses
conseils municipaux de leurs compétences
y compris d'ailleurs dans l'opposition
car si nous gagnons hénin-beaumont
demain c'est parce que pendant des
années nous avons démontré comme
conseils municipaux d'opposition que
nous avions les clés les solutions et la
maîtrise de la gestion d'une
municipalité il ya une autre ville qui
est importante c'est marseille on vous
donne deuxième pour le moment dans les
sondages ça veut dire que en gros vous
allez faire l'élection est ce que vous
êtes prête à donner un coup de main à la
droite locale
mais écoutez encore une fois nous
verrons tout cela si c'est pour donner
un mandat supplémentaire à monsieur
gaudin dont nous considérons qu'il a
horriblement mal géré c'est le gone
alors là mais vous ne savez pas vous
savez vous aussi ça monsieur gaudin qui
sera candidat on ne sait même pas encore
alors attendons ne soyons pas c'est que
cette fois je trouve étonnant si vous
voulez danser municipal et dans le
discours ambiant qui est délivrée par
les adversaires politiques
c'est qu'ils passent leur vie à dire oh
là là le front national ils sont nuls en
gestion des municipalités ce
épouvantable ça va être épouvantable
mais s'il considère que ça va être si
épouvantable alors pourquoi méthyle
autant d'énergie à nous empêcher de
gagner ont tendance à gagner qui nous
laisse gagner quelques villes comme ça
et puis comme ça ils seront tranquilles
non la réalité c'est qu'ils savent
pertinemment que nous ferons évidemment
nos preuves et ce qui les inquiète c'est
que nous soyons dans la cale en capacité
de donner aux français la preuve que
nous serons loyaux que nous respecterons
nos promesses et que nous améliorerons
concrètement la situation et la vie des
habitants
mais marine le pen je manquais ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui le fn est en mesure
de gérer des villes alors qu'il a fait
plutôt la preuve par le passé que
c'était pas le cas qu'est ce qui fait la
différence aujourd'hui
mais encore une fois parce que je vous
l'expliquais tout à l'heure je vous ai
dit que voilà il y avait une peut-être
une erreur de stratégie qui a été fait
aujourd'hui la situation est différente
nous sommes aussi peut-être
professionnaliser nous avons fait un
gros travail de terrain gros travail de
formation et b soucier à mon avis va
donner évidemment va donner ses fruits
et nous pourrons encore une fois à
partir le moment nous sommes dans laxe
de changer les choses mais au niveau des
municipalités et bien ne pas commettre
quelques erreurs qui ont pu être
commises dans le passé pour produire
peut-être un mois des européennes qui
viennent qui viendront derrière d'abord
est-ce que vous confirmez que vous-même
serai candidate
oui bien sûr je serai candidate dans ma
région qu'en est il de votre père il
sera candidate en paca d'accord est ce
que vous envisagez de vous associer avec
des souverainistes comme nicolas dupont
aignan ont dit qu'ils allaient donner un
coup de main robert ménard à béziers g
nous avons monté le rassemblement bleu
marine
nous rassemblons bleue marine est une
association qui réunit des mouvements
politiques patriotes qui viennent
d'ailleurs de droite ou de gauche
si monsieur dupont-aignan considère que
la situation de la france est si grave
et si urgente qu'il faut maintenant
fédérer les forces
patriotique et qu'il veut en faire
partie eh bien il connaît mon numéro de
téléphone
on comprend pas très bien l'articulation
entre le front national et puis sur
l'assemblement qui porte votre nom c'est
très simple le front national est un
parti politique le rassemblement bleue
marine est une fédération de partis
politiques voilà une fédération pour
présenter des listes communes en quelque
sorte de 2,2 de rassemblement lors des
différents salons dédiés à votre
personne donc puisque je porte votre
prénom
non c'est pas entièrement dédié à ma
personne c'est c'était un clin d'oeil
qui avait été fait aux cantonales ça a
plutôt bien marché
les français s'en sont saisis il n'y
avait pas de raison si vous voulez de
leur retirer cette ce terme-là vous
inquiétez pas j'ai pas la tête qui a
gonflé elle n'est pas elle ne menace pas
d'exploser mais aucune inquiétude face à
succomber au culte de la personne n'a
dit non non pas du tout pas du tout aux
européennes toujours il vous avez dit
que vous pouviez faire campagne avec un
néerlandais qui s'appelle gertwiller du
parti de la liberté à marseille vous
avez dit que
vous ne vouliez discriminer personne
aucune religion en particulier lui en
revanche avec le coran il est plutôt
extrêmement dur il l'a comparé il a
comparé ce texte à mein kampf et il veut
même l'interdire aux pays bas il n'y a
pas une énorme contradiction non
monsieur garde gildas nous faisons pas
en france donc je ne veux pas les
campagnes mais je n'ai pas dit que je
ferai campagne puis j'ai envisagé de
chardy que j'ai envie je je je je pense
qu'il est utile que les partis
patriotiques européens se réunissent
dans un ce qu'on appelle un parti
politique européen
ça existe c'est le ppe pour la droite
c'est le ps pour la gauche
et nous nous avons un mouvement qui
s'appelle l'alliance européenne des
libertés dans lequel il ya des
mouvements qui sont des mouvements très
eurosceptique et qu'ils partagent mais
je le dis dans la même interview vous
pouvez pas l'ignorer
dans la même interview que vous citez
j'ai dit nous avons une sensibilité
différente sur ce sujet mais je ne lutte
pas contre une religion mais moi je suis
française et donc je suis tout imprégné
de la laïcité à la française que ne
connaissent pas du tout les pays bas ça
n'est pas dans leur culture ça n'est pas
dans leur culture politique et par
conséquent je n'essaye pas d'appliquer
aux autres ma propre grille de lecture
voilà mais il est sûr que monsieur
wylder c'est un anti union européenne
comme nous que il en dénonce les ravages
sur le plan économique sur le plan
social sur le plan de la souveraine de
tous qui sommes opposés qu'il est opposé
à l'immigration massive et anarchique
que il est opposé à l'islam
al issaoui et moi je suis opposé au
fondamentalisme islamique voilà c'est
une différence entre nous dernière
question refait alors est-ce que si vous
êtes réélu vous continuerez de rémunérer
louis aliot comme assistant
parlementaire comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui nuit sera élu aussi par
conséquent il ne sera plus hélas mon
assistant parlementaire
je vais avoir bien du mal à le remplacer
je vous cache pas merci maintenant
perrine tarneaud public sénat nous
rejoint avant cela peut-il saint-geniès
explore la recomposition politique en
cours autour du
populaires et des classes moyennes
travail production lutte contre la
précarité
après l'insécurité c'est l'insécurité
économique qui est au coeur du discours
frontiste et dimanche dernier à
marseille
marine le pen a réaffirmé ses solutions
comme le protectionnisme ou encore la
sortie de l'euro
si la tentation du front national gagne
certains sympathisants ump
l'économie reste pourtant le point de
divergence entre les deux électorats les
deux électorats ne sont pas aujourd'hui
en osmose complète il n'y a pas de
fusion totale
il ya encore des différences assez
marquées notamment sur les questions
économiques et sociales
on voit que l'électorat ump demeure très
très occupés par la dégradation de la
compétitivité de l'économie française
qu'il est très préoccupée par la
question de la dette et des déficits
publics
autant de préoccupations qui sont pas au
coeur des attentes et des sujets
d'intérêt de l'électorat du front
national
pourtant le discours de proximité du fn
séduit de plus en plus parmi les milieux
populaires et les classes moyennes
bien au delà du chant traditionnel
frontiste tout se passe à fait comme si
après avoir siphonné tout ce qu'ils
pouvaient s'ils me faune et au sein de
l'électorat ump et bien marine le pen
comprenez qu'aujourd'hui sa marge de
progression se situer sur la gauche
comme la déception est forte dans
l'électorat de gauche est en partie de
l'électorat populaire la déception de
françois hollande bien un acteur à qui
devient captif pour le front national
les laissés pour compte des partis
traditionnels se reporte ainsi vers le
fn le seul selon eux eu à prendre en
compte leurs problèmes pour suivre cette
émission je crois que nous sommes
parfaitement crédible sur le plan
économique et un certain nombre et un
nombre de plus en plus important
d'ailleurs d'économistes rejoignent
ou défendre d'ailleurs sans le rejoint
le maire défendre les positions qui sont
celles du front national voilà beaucoup
de français se rendre compte que le
modèle économique qu'on leur a vendu et
qu'on leur a imposé est un modèle
économique qui rend la france en
faillite en réalité qui est en train de
tuer notre modèle social et que cette
compétitivité dont on parlait tout à
l'heure
plutôt que de la retrouver par
l'intermédiaire de la monnaie et bien on
est en train d'essayer de la retrouver
par l'intermédiaire de la déflation
salariale de l'effondrement du système
du système social par une politique
d'austérité
donc je considère que c'est une erreur
majeure et presque même un crime social
le fn a revendiqué le slogan de reggane
l'état n'est pas la solution était le
problème
est-ce que vous conservez c'est très
fermé à l'époque l'état pouvait être un
problème parce que la france était
souveraine qu'elle était qu elle mais
qu'elle maîtrisait ses frontières
qu'elle n'est pas victime de la
concurrence internationale déloyale
aujourd'hui le problème c'est le
mondialisme c'est la concurrence
internationale déloyale c'est le le
libre
la libre concurrence comme ils disent et
qui est en train de ruiner notre
agriculture
regardez le problème aujourd'hui par
exemple c'est l'accord de libre échange
avec deux lieux avec les états unis qui
va être un véritable ravage pour
l'agriculture et pour l'industrie
française qu'a contrario vous condamner
la société de consommation qui
finalement nous pousse beaucoup de
ménages vers l'insolvabilité
mais non mais c'est pas le problème le
nom mais moi je suis pour une économie
libre les choses sont très claires
je crois à la libre entreprise je crois
d'ailleurs au génie français et rallye
je crois je crois mais je crois à des
frontières je crois aussi un état
stratège empoté je suis en centrant
quelque sorte
sur le plan économique je crois un état
stratège je pense qu'on ne peut pas
laisser le marché tout faire je crois
que il ne régule rien qu'ils tuent par
ses excès par ces abus donc voilà je
pense que par exemple jeu contiendrait
je pense que par exemple l'état a quand
même des moyens de pression sur total
qui est en train de fermer l'usiné
l'usiné de carling en mettant à la porte
de 120 personnes alors qu'ils ont fait
10 me
à de chiffre d'affaires en 2012 voilà ce
que je crois certains ghz avec un cône
est finalement la même chose que jean
luc mélenchon c'est un peu l'impression
qu'on à cet instant précis
si on excepte non m côté l'immigration
et muse oui mais c'est d'abord être
d'abord c'est que comme vous dites c'est
ces deux côtés c'est très lourd comme
changement parce que parce que les même
occasion elle sert justement à soutenir
la déflation salariale elle sert à peser
à la baisse sur les salaires
et puis jean luc mélenchon il ne veut
pas de protectionnisme à nos frontières
or les français ils veulent un
protectionnisme à nos frontières
ils veulent que ont recours fois on se
lance dans la reconquête du marché
intérieur et que on protège les
productions françaises et donc les
salariés français de la concurrence
internationale déloyale
il n'est pas sur cette ligne là monsieur
monsieur mélenchon et c'est ce qui fait
effectivement deux énormes différences
entre nous l'assemblée nationale a
adopté la loi du faux sur le logement
qui instaure une 40 y est universelle
sur les loyers impayés est ce que c'est
une bonne mesure selon vous pour
protéger les propriétaires alors si je
vous rappelle juste d'une mesure qui
était dans mon programme et
présidentielle sauf que à chaque fois
que les socialistes se saisit de mesures
il en faut une machine à fabriquer les
mégots quoi c'est à dire que ça va pas
c'est à dire que ce truc là ça ne
fonctionnera pas et c'est triste parce
que parce que c'est ma utc technique
mais c'est mal fichu voilà moi je
pensais qu effectivement met en place
une garantie des loyers même site une
garantie automobile pouvait être une
bonne idée mais à charge les garanties
contre les impayés
oui il est à charge pour l'état d'aller
lui même se donner les moyens de la
puissance publique pour pouvoir
récupérer les sommes qui ne sont pas
versées sas avait un avantage c'est que
ça permettait aux propriétaires de
continuer à investir dans la pierre si
vous voulez sans avoir la crainte de
l'ain pays qui parfois est dramatique
pour les personnes âgées par exemple
pour les jeunes couples et en même temps
permettre aux salariés français de
pouvoir accéder à une location sans
qu'on leur demande la garantie de leurs
parents de leurs grands-parents de
gagner quatre ou cinq fois le montant
de leur loyer vous le répéter plusieurs
fois en ce moment et encore dans cette
émission on s'est professionnalisé est
ce que ça veut dire que vous ouvrez un
droit d'inventaire sur les damnés jean
marie le pen
non ça veut dire que nous étions un
parti jeune et que par conséquent plus
comme nous sommes maintenant en
situation d'exercer le pouvoir
il pèse sur nous et évidemment des
responsabilités encore plus lourdes que
quand nous étions un mouvement dont
l'objectif était déjà de briser les
tabous pour l'aimer pour mettre au
centre de deux des débats des sujets qui
étaient occultés par la vie politique
française
vous êtes tout à fait dans la continuité
idéologique par rapport à votre père
donc oui mais c'est parce que ça veut
dire aller moi je fais pas d'idéologie
monsieur moi je fais du pragmatisme moi
je fais pas d'idéologie jeu pas là pour
défendre une idéologie je suis là pour
diagnostiquer les problèmes des français
y apporter des réponses c'est bien
d'ailleurs pour ça que les partis
traditionnels ne répondent plus aux
préoccupations des français parce que
ils sont dans l'idéologie et même si la
situation change
même si ils se rendent compte de l'échec
des politiques qu'ils défendent
eh bien j'ai connu six ans on n'avait de
valeur d'idées le comice sont dans
l'idéologie ils ne tiennent pas compte
de la réalité
mais non monsieur c'est quoi les mois je
suis patriote
j'aime mon pays je veux se défendre je
pense que partout en toutes
circonstances il faut penser à défendre
l'intérêt de la france et des français
avant tout si pour vous c'est une
idéologie
écoutez je vous laisse jamais c'est tout
pas pour moi une idéologie c'est le vrai
pragmatique votre père raconte souvent
comme si la vessie et c'est vrai que
c'est de pouvoir en 2002 on adore
si si c'est si oui parce que vous ne
parlez que de nuit voilà donc il a
souvent raconté que s'il avait accédé au
pouvoir en 2002 il n'aurait pas su chi
nommé chez notamment comme secrétaire
général de l'elysée le premier ministre
vous vous ne me rien qui aujourd'hui je
le sais mais je vous le dirai pas ah oui
puisque c'est complètement hors sujet
voilà donc moi je le dire aux français
qu'ils sont réels mais vous le savez
très bien vous en voyez quand même vous
voyez des tas de gens de qualité autour
autour de moi vous voyez des experts
vous voyez des amiraux en ce qui
concerne la défense
vous voyez des géopoliticiens sert la
politique la politique nationale
je vois bien vous voyez des il ya des
économistes
vous voyez des gens vous voulez
peut-être pas les voir mais croyez moi
ils sont là et je les présenterai aux
français le moment venu
et d'ailleurs je les présente aux
français au fur et à mesure du temps qui
nous sépare de la future élection
présidentielle
vous mettrez jean roucas à la culture tu
pas du tout sûr qu'il ait envie de ça à
marseille lors de votre discours
dimanche dernier vous avez dit les
hommes politiques inspirent aujourd'hui
le dégoût date un peu dure vis-à-vis de
vous même nom jeu mais je crois très
honnêtement que ceux qui nous ont
dirigés et ça n'est pas mon cas ceux qui
nous ont dirigés inspire le dégoût
oui les batailles d'ego les batailles de
personnes les bataille d'ambitions
inspire le dégoût français je penserai
maintenant ne rien révéler en disant
cela je pense qu'il ya une pensée y
faisait mais que les autres je pense
qu'il faut une autre manière de faire de
la politique je pense que tous ceux qui
ont fait des promesses et les ont pas
tenus
des gouttes les français alors oui je
jeu évidemment j'envisage de faire les
choses autrement voyez-vous et de
respecter le mandat pour lequel j'aurais
été élu c'est à dire appliquer les idées
politiques pour lesquelles j'aurais été
les respecter les objectifs que j'aurais
donné aux français
j'ai été élu pour faire ça j'ai pas été
élu pour faire l' inverse
nicolas sarkozy ils avaient été vus pour
réduire l'immigration il l'aggravé
françois hollande il a été élu pour
faire du social il fait de
l'ultralibéralisme et ils fabriquent des
impôts tous les jours voir respecter
juste ce pour quoi on a été élu ça
paraît pas très compliqué donc la gauche
des français ce sont les extrêmes qui
les rassemble oui je crois d'abord je
suis je refuse cette formulation
d'extrême car je ne vois pas ce qu'il
y'a d'extrême dans le projet pour la
france que je présente je le trouve au
contraire extrêmement raisonnable et
effectivement je pense que c'est le seul
capable d'unir les français dans un
grand projet dans un grand dessein et
d'arrêter de voir les français en
fonction de leurs origines ou de la
religion pour des raisons clientéliste
les français sont des français ils sont
français avant d'être n'importe quoi
d'autre et l'objectif de l'état c'est de
leur apporter une égalité sans tenir
compte justement de cesser ces
différences qui doivent en tout cas dans
le regard de la delà de la deûle et à
être lisse et des questions pour finir
j'ai lu vous vouliez supprimer le
smartphone ne croyez pas aux mécanismes
non je n'y crois plus j'ai vraiment
senti parce que si vous voulez j'ai le
sentiment que le sénat est coûteux et
somme toute à part défendre ses propres
intérêts en refusant d'ailleurs de voter
le non cumul des mandats qui pourtant
est réclamée par les français est une
chambre de défense d'elle-même elle
allonge considérablement les procédures
et à mon avis comme je les dis dans
certains projets de loi n'ont bike ou
des non je crois parce que c'est plus
est pas obligatoire compte tenu de ce
que j'en vois ça me paraît être un coût
et un allongement des procédures
relativement inutile
marine le pen à ce que vous êtes pour la
pénalisation des clients de prostituées
et un rapport parlementaire qui le
recommande cette semaine et une
proposition de loi qui va être déposé au
parlement français je pense que c'est
toujours le même problème c'est le même
problème que pour le même problème que
pour le cannabis si vous voulez là soit
on lutte contre le cannabis et à ce
moment là il faut pénaliser les
consommateurs
si on veut lutter contre la prostitution
à ce moment là il faut lutter contre les
consommateurs mais je crois pas que soit
l'urgence
moi je vous dis très forte très
facilement je pense que l'urgence
absolue c'est de lutter contre les
réseaux criminels qui se sont
développées au bénéfice il faut lui dire
non
arthur des frontières parce que quand on
n'a plus de frontières ben on a plus de
contrôle aux frontières et donc ça a
entraîné une explosion des réseaux
mafieux et des réseaux criminels qui se
sont installés sur notre territoire et
contre lequel à mon avis il n'ya pas de
lutte sérieuse qui est menée pourquoi
est ce que les frontières seraient ne
sera pas synonyme d'ouverture vous nous
parlez toujours vous attaquez toujours
les frontières mais errants se dit vous
pouvez nous proposer peut-être un repli
qui serait mortifère et pourquoi on a
toujours eu des frontières dans toute
l'histoire de france et on n'a jamais
été dans un repli mortifère les
etats-unis ont des frontières la chine a
des frontières le brésil a des
frontières
tous les pays tous les sont ouverts sur
le plan économique au vous croyez ça à
lachine est ouvert sur le plan
économique mais j'ai pas eu mais ils
sont ouverts sur le plan économique
oui quand c'est non c'est non
heureusement que les frontières sont au
ghana europe en avertir un débouché
monsieur quant au sein de leur conseil
des services essentiels et messieurs je
ne peux pas fermer les frontières je
veux les maîtriser un accord et je veux
décider éventuellement de d'y apporter
des restrictions lorsque c'est notre
intérêt d'y apporter des restrictions si
c'est pas de notre intérêt est bien à ce
moment là on n'y apporte pas dans tel ou
tel domaine de restrictions on n'a pas
parlé de politique internationale marine
le pen vous avez dénoncé le belliciste
françois hollande
quel mode que vous utilisez ce sera avec
la dernière question pour bachar
el-assad dont le régime porte bien la
responsabilité de l'effroyable massacre
chimiques comme le rapport de l'onu
lancé fou fait non c'est faux dans le
rapport de l'onu il n'y a pas de
responsable que tout soit pointé du
doigt le responsable est clairement des
éminences les roquettes sol-sol seul le
courant mais c'est le foot c'est fou et
vous le faites les stocks de poissons
gsm
c'est faux et l'allemagne le dis que
c'est faux d'ailleurs ben j'en dis pas
la russie parce que sinon on va te dira
poutine etc
l'allemagne a indiqué à donner des
éléments extrêmement précis et vous
savez pertinemment qu'il y a des
arsenaux chimiques c'est madame carla
del ponte d'ailleurs qu'il l'avait
dénoncé commissaire à l'onu qui sont
tombés en amour qui sont morts pour
christ et parce que les mains des
rebelles c'est parce que j'ai dit je dis
que je ne sais pas en l'occurrence qui
est responsable de ces de ceux de ce
massacre chimiques
même si je considère que les autres
massacres sont tout aussi terrible car
l'éventration par les fragments
bon ben je sais pas s'il faut faire une
hiérarchie en l'occurrence dans
l'horreur mais je considère qu'il ya
entre une commande hier on a résolu en
tout cas semble-t-il par la voie
diplomatique
le problème de ces armes chimiques et
tout le monde s'en sent mieux et ça
n'est pas grâce à françois hollande
contrairement à ce qu'il dit puisque
pour le chef de l'état français la firme
était à prier merci m'arrive de pnb
semaine prochaine
marisol touraine la ministre des
affaires sociales et de la santé sera
notre invité bonsoir